الحرب مواجهه مفتوحه احيانا تتجاوز ظروف
الزمن والمكان من شرق اوكرانيا الى غرب
روسيا تستمر الاحداث المتسارعه حدث مقاطعه
داخل التراب الروسي قد يغير المعادله
ويفتح جبهه جديده المخابره الاوكرانيه
قالت ان الهجوم نفذه معارضون من الداخل ضد
نظام بوتين ويريدون القضاء عليه الرئيس
الروسي الذي الغى رحلته التي كانت مخططا
لها الى
الهجوم بالارهابي فكيف تريد اليوم نفذوا
هجوما ارهابيا اخر نفذوا جريمه اخرى على
منطقه حدوديه وفتحوا النار على مدنيين رغم
رؤيتهم بان السياره مدنيه ويجلس فيها
مدنيون واطفال هؤلاء الاشخاص اخذوا على
عاتقهم مهمه انتزاع ذاكرتنا وتاريخنا
وعاداتنا وحتى لغتنا ورغم ان المجموعه
التي نفذت الهجوم نشرت مقطعا مصورا
لعناصرها داخل المقاطعه
وهم يرفعون شعار الجيش الاوكراني قال
مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان الهجوم مفبرك ومزيف الى ذلك تبنت
المجموعه التي اغتالت ابنه المفكر الروسي
المقرب من الكرملين الكسندر دوغان الهجمات
تطور جديد قد يغير مسار الحرب رغم انفي
صلتها بالموضوع خلال الوجداني العربيه